es imposible no ver esa camioneta por
las calles de madrid sus llamativos
carteles rosas promocionan una oferta
peculiar un divorcio por sólo 150 euros
el abogado alberto garcía cebrián ha
inventado este vehículo le bautizamos
como el nombre de divorcio neta como
algo comercial como un marketing que
pretende dar cercanía a algo tan lejano
como el divorcio con sus divorcio netas
el abogado quiere romper el tabú del
divorcio uno de nuestros lemas es juntos
o separados pero felices estamos
acostumbrando a la gente a que el
divorcio no se vea como un drama sino
simplemente una decisión una opción que
puede poner una solución a una familia
esta manera de pensar convenció a javier
conocía a su mujer desde más de 20 años
y decidió dar el paso trabajábamos nos
veíamos - y el conocimiento que ha
provocado que tenemos mucho tiempo
juntos y ahí tomar la decisión pues que
hemos arreglado más el negocio del
divorcio a bajo costo nunca había tenido
tanto éxito por el primer confinamiento
vino
la nhtsa de divorcios y lo que decían
era que querían divorciarse rápido
urgentemente para que si venía otro
confinamiento no le pillará con la misma
compañía en el tercer trimestre del 2020
justo después del primer confinamiento
hubo entre un 15 y 20 por ciento más
divorcios que los años anteriores
para alberto es una tendencia que
seguirá creciendo muchas gracias
para este psicólogo el fenómeno apenas
se acaba de empezar se han separado
todavía pues porque no les ha dado
tiempo acudir a los juzgados o no tienen
dinero para una separación porque una
separación es cara
y se han tenido que quedar sobre el
papel dentro de su relación pero
emocionalmente están las parejas rotas
otra consecuencia del confinamiento el
número de bodas se han desplomado porque
han sido aplazadas 2020 podría ser el
primer año con un número mayor de
divorcios que matrimonios en españa